I'm i'm alive again. All right. A lot.
I should explain it a bit like this.
I'm an economist and a researcher
and i know what you can
do with statistics.
With statistics you used
to package the philosophy
and you can do it anywhere you want to.
So you can look at bill
and cliff as a village
and you can brush it with the
the pta of welfare dependency
and say look this got a
taxpayer so much money
and it's being done the same
time that with the other side.
The reason why there was welfare
dependency here was it was created by
systematically was going any asset we had
into local council conditions including
five million dollar.
Bridges and fifty thousand dollar
roads and was and the amount of cost.
So we never could build a commercial
infrastructure was denied.
Secondly even if that
wouldn't have taken place.
You must value a model
that can make out of a hundred thousand
dollar property a 10 million dollar
property within 10 years time each
and every individual who had no money 10
years ago now got a home worth 50 60 70
thousand dollars unencumbered
by the banking system.
We changed a property as john said it could
not support one farmer family could not
have had a work of the land and now
supporting 80 families and in time.
Well one it adds to the national
assets 10 million bucks.
Which is a lot more than this village ever
got into yourselves security receipts
and secondly it actually just a very thing
that everybody's talking about now which
is ecologic sustainable development.
You're nurtured in earth rod and poison
if you take control of your own.
I've on having it ruled yet you produce
your own product for them to import them
and you feel the community values are
there people here more buy more their own
gear these days.
Become less dependent on exports
from less depend on the motorcar
and brings tourist dollars in by
showing other people how to do this.
This is what third stage in this latest
deal is on about now we've gone for
in kraft we've gone for farmers.
With processed food dried
food and nursery at a nursery
and then we're going for some sort
of eco tourism these other things
that the infrastructure that will make
it worthwhile for tourists to come here
and have a look at but a year 2000.
It will be very very
difficult to buy into bill
and cliff's very difficult
it will be family plots
and they won't leave the
family to be that valuable.
It'll be a training institute
for this lifestyle
and a tactical him right around to the
world because we offer here now all the
things that we were dreaming about
and just to bring about in the
cities which is to have a fresh air.
You have no payments to degrade you don't
pollute to degrade you have a you grow
beautiful food. You know how to
do the healing arts and so on.
So.
That process of eco tourism is taking place now
it's a regional thing we started something
which is catching fire regionally now
and it can't intervene when as well.
It is a topic which needs discussion at
length because the community itself must
put a values on how much they will sell
out to the great god mammon in order to
become independent right now we are
already depend of the system as a as a
lifestyle. In fact anything wrong
with the whole aquarius thing.
It is that it has been
supported to the point
that it is weak at the knees
it can walk on to something.
Any more is totally so security dependent
and to have a true philosophy
for the next century
and we hope an eclipse is in
fact a leading part of this.
It must become financially independent.
You gotta roll to get your sat river you
cannot keep on saying i'm for the ferry
mean yeah yeah.
By the way.
Mine.
That that has happened and there
are still a few private places.
Right. Okay sure the strata title.
It didn't really improve people's
chances of making more money.
It just made it easier for people to buy
because on a straight a title they could
get a larger than whereas on a multiple
occupancy you could on a multiple occupancy.
Let's say a house that's
for sale here for 80 grand
and will probably be sold very quickly on
a multiple occupancy you might be lucky
and get 24.
Because you can't borrow money on the
strength that much runtime you get two
or three. Yes you would just be very
lucky to get any sort of money back.
Well that was one of the.
When we had to go for the strata title
a lot of people didn't want back here.
You know and we had to look at all.
It was about five alternatives
that we had to study
and the strata title
came out as the winner.
Now we knew that the offshoot of
that immediately was a lot more rights
because we'd have to pay individual rights
to lismore council as well
as our internal levies here.
So a lot of people didn't want
it but it was the only way
and one of the ups of that is if already
one of the multitude of breeze. Yes.
And people have to move away.
They can get as much they can get enough
money to probably set themselves up
somewhere else.
After a fashion rather than have to walk
out with nothing in them so distraught
is work. Good in that way but it has allowed
people to take a capital investment
but the ones who want to sell well
we really want them to sell and go
and maybe somebody else comes in who doesn't
want to sell you know generally people
in a mall or in places like
billingsley do not want to sell
and hang on to the lifestyle because
there's very little outside there you can
compare it with
but you've got to recognize something
must have mainstream values
and i think one of the things
that we are particularly interested in
this to build a bridge between mainstream
and you'll turn it is because we've got
to integrate where once all we are male
and female inside you know you
have in the nyang fire and water.
It's that that capitalism
communism developed he must go
and there must be a bridge
build and that bridge means
that your average person can
actually attain the lifestyle
that we are society now proclaim
to be ecologically sustainable.
Yeah and to do that you must have
a model that a large to do so.
I wonder things and i can be clear about
bill in clashes when you listen to it
when listen to ourself talking it seems
like an enclave of a club almost how do you
get in. How do you achieve
things like this not true.
You come in and you go
like any other village.
It is no you don't know everybody on
the property division people who are
speculators who never are here.
There are people who are active committee
members who are they'll be meeting there
is hermits. There's a who work in town
and don't let a lot much it's a village
and it's easy to get an in-out. And
that sends the bridge is important.
Because if you tell the average person in
the city the world's falling apart the
bombs about to drop to flank
us this is about to collapse.
Blah blah all the whole city is going to
do you know it's no good if you can see
the food the more you can someone
be on that beach any more.
And you say what you alternate world in
multiple occupancy you've got no rights at
home. One is grand. Can we sell the place
and you have local council fighting you
so bilic list was set up to say to the
mainstream person. Yes you can do it.
You've got the safety of private property.
You have all the benefits of a
socially conscious infrastructure.
Policy. Creating.
Military asked him you know i
don't reserve and i don't i think
that that's a kind of if he is.
You know that a bit of nimbin if he
bullshit that everyone around to it
when i have been around
yeah okay i've got a t.v..
I don't watch it all the time
but i like to play the odd video we like
to drink fruit juice. We've got a mixer.
We've got three panels out there.
I came here where i had a many
lives before i came here in
1975 i was an insert two thousand
dollars a year as a training officer.
I had a bit of bread. It ran out rapidly.
But you know we've got a few solar panels
but there's no one here who hasn't
got one solar panel where i came
when we landed here.
Our power source was our car battery
which i carried into the house
and ruined 100 to read indian beautiful
indian muslim chair then i got two car
batteries one.
Oh i had one in the car
and one in the house
and only had to change them once a
week. Nevertheless it's their handle.
Then to family and stuff. Come to john
it but it's. Because. As we live.
Like this it does not mean to say
that there are certain things in
technology that we don't want.
I'm not afraid of technology. I
love it if it's appropriate.
I'm not drawing it doesn't take me for
barolo does of coal to fire up a bloody
great power house to boil a cup of water.
You know do something really
interesting at the root of debt and
that is if mainstream
didn't have the answers.
It has the answer we didn't live like
achieve it. You know the occupancy.
I've got to say this is just as wrong
and i'm not knocking multiple occupancy
because they have been a life raft for many
people still are and still
are you today will be.
And as i said i don't know if they've got
their place but as a social experiment.
It is essentially flawed and the
reason why communism is breaking down
and in russia is because
that old communist model of common
ownership just doesn't work.
I'm not saying that it couldn't
work in some idealists society.
But in the here and now on this earth.
It just doesn't work because there is some
people who will steal who will obstruct
who will be too paranoid to participate.
It falls apart as fall apart
and seychelles and fall apart
and now to flanders told part and russia.
It's followed by the nimbin now it may
well fall apart because establishment is
pushing it rapidly along a
good it wants to collapse.
But basically you do need some
of that what you said was
that gentrifying establishment feeling.
We all need to have a base and i
myself find private property.
I have a problem with that notion.
I do believe in a lifelong
lease of ownership
and that's how i regard
our torrance title.
I know it's not like that
but it higher regard it.
We were originally set up here to lease.
The land from ourselves. And when we die.
It goes back to the community.
You know but that's not the
system we work and that we have
but we are approximating it
closely. There is nothing wrong.
In fact it is very necessary to find
that bridge between where
you say no this is mine
and what you say you know
i've got to share here
and mainstream society is
overly too much in a head trip.
They get all the right answers but no
one can actually do without the friends
and they want can do without
the infrastructure.
So we flush of problems down
the toilet and we just say
and wish for a better world if you
go to the multiple occupancy scene.
You actually live the ideal lifestyle.
But you can never actually
satisfy those few basic needs
that are coming up every once in
a while like you are dirt poor
and your teeth follow a path on
you or your marriage falls apart
and you can't sell your
house and you're stuck.
So you need an interim thing where
you have all the right philosophies
that christ came up with the same time
and then bite size of society
at large and that sense.
Yeah that actually works
on a human level as well.
Yeah
and i think that's what we've got in i
think we are we are not saying we are the
ultimate we are a stepping stone
from that one way street to nowhere.
The community.
You see that's what they try to do to us
they try to shunt us down a one way street.
And that's when we said no. And.
When i say that i'm not being
derogatory about the places
or the people they came at their
time and they served their purpose
but they didn't spread. You know
so really it was a cocooned trip.
Now we believe that the time is.
Coming where we're going to have to spread
and we believe there'll
be places for like ours.
You see my greatest dream is to see
undone a 60 year massacre of trees
that took place through this big scrub i
would like to see a hundred year project
set to read green the big scrap
and it would be done by the
young folk who can do the work.
It could involve kindergarden and primary
school through our secondary schools
and through our universities.
It could within 10 years it would
be such a major tourist attraction
that it would fund itself.
Kids have got nothing to do give them
something to take them to some land
and this you work this land for five years
and replanted next gives you the right
to live on their land for as long as you
live. This is what we've got to do and
we've got to do it in a massive way
and this big scrub area here would be
the ideal place to start would him
involved.
Every village in every little town
could participate immediately
and put their youth to work but sell it
to them and make it as popular as skin.
It is admin is in berlin. You know make
them our skinheads the tree painters.
So we've got to let them go their set them
up with camps let them have their music.
Let them have a smoke a
doubt if they want it.
Not too much alcohol that like alcohol.
I do see both very very.
Clearly acidity the problem that mainstream
when you live in a place like this.
When you have people as you saw a year
or two ago killing each other for the
right to sleep in a public toilet
and all related to death by a teenage girl
for the right to sleep in a toilet our
society. Actually creates all this angst
on the television you're being told
that the old zone layer is falling apart
and the job prospects and you and
that you are being caged into the system
clock sometimes a collapse because
when you want to go out
you can't buy the land.
All the great revolutions
around the world.
All of them have been about ownership
of land. Make no mistake about it.
Multitude was about land.
The french revolution of that
land it's all about land
and the land in australia today is managed
or i should say mismanaged
to old world concepts
that are in essence saying the local
inhabitant has no right to exist he
susceptible and the local resources
are there to be exploited.
So we're now shifting into the 21st century
where we're saying exploitation is over
roads rain timbers are
made in the cabinets.
Now we actually have to face a
problem actually living here.
We've got to change european
dominated australian culture.
Anglicized to some extent what ever it
is into a truly local culture and for
that reason they don't we
built a model for bill
and cliff emotionally within ourselves we
borrowed a lot from knowing debt ridden
you cultivate all the pacific
islander culture and niman
and i'm tenement tenable yeah
and that's an interesting thing about this
level of communism as to how deep you
should go before you reach equity
when you go to original inhabitants the
lifestyle which are living today still in
cape york and as you know we work.
There is not wanting communism there is a
chief who holds certain large amount of
land interest for the population.
So when someone gets married in.
A bit of land there is systems of
ownership even operating on that level.
So we have the same systems here we must
create the same systems are not what you
say anyway belongs to everybody and
iki has been the enemy from within.
For us adri really hard to do as we can as
i said to be philosophy are real problem.
On the outside it has been overbearing
system on the inside it have been the worst
for thinkers who want to be left alone.
You know one anarchist studio is.
Can make more trouble than 20 on is it
but i've always been a bit anarchistic
myself so i could understand an occasion.
What you have to do you have to present
the bill and clear. Whatever happens.
You have to go to the residence meeting
and you just if you want something to happen
you just have to present a better case
than the ones who don't want to.
You know and it really is
a low level democracy.
You know we've got about
seventy four families here
and we have a resident meeting
once a month the residents
make all the decisions about everything
that meeting is usually
attended by about 30.
Residents a core group who are always
and odd ones who float in because there
might be a top a from their some.
It's basically it's a business meeting
and it should be transplant into suburban
australia it's youtube of course it
should be of course to empower
neighborhood you got to start talking
and if you have people running around
your neighborhood there are not doing
anything to give them a job replanting
cleaning the sidewalks up helping the old
lady with her herd who are her meal.
So we come soberly begin our system
we forgotten about the little people
and really want to start.
Looking no matter how difficult a process
is wonderful things happen on a job you
know when issues are contentious
debate can get pretty heated.
But if nothing else here.
We respect the chair.
So i think you know all the ten years
i've ever been here i've only tended one
meeting where the chair
couldn't control the me and
that was a really nasty so.
You know our politics a pretty good here
so people who lobby get things done
but if the majority of people
don't think it's a good idea.
It doesn't get a deal.
Well the acquired idea was 20 years
old. You know couch man came to me.
And when really water
when he he asked the question if
not one twenty five times he says
but what happened to all the i do you know
all these young ebenezer changed your
middle age you show me any
group of people in society.
You haven't changed in the last 20
years and i say yes it's a graveyard.
Everybody changes. Everybody.
I also want to point out that that the
aquarian ideal never was owned by noon.
It was owned by everybody.
And it was in poland that it was
in amsterdam it was in california.
It was here. We just made one shrine.
For christ first of all 1973 which allowed
australians to have one place to go to
what you could sit and think
about this wonderful columbus
that you actually are peaceful.
And organic and and sharing and so
on and none of this is completely
and all of us try to be a little bit.
So i see aquarius now everywhere
to me when i look at society.
It's very green all those philosophies
which were expanded 73 are now everywhere
here and i can be here
and happily talk about aquarius even
though i wasn't here not you 73 it wasn't
california i didn't come here until 79
and yet i feel the same philosophy
because i share with all the other ones
that feeling that we are part
of sponsible for the planet
and we are optimistic i do something
about it and with that ice.
I realize that would indeed rock
aceh from canberra to have to perth.
Sane people as opposed to put it
in a nutshell for me the essence
of the 20 years is in the
development of what you see
when you drive around this knowledge.
That's the aquarium to me is
here living strong gradings
gaining strength every day more more
people putting trees in more more people
concerned about environmental issues more
and more people writing
letters about those matters
and people get involved in the things
that we held dear then we didn't realise
just what the problems were then to what
we know now we have a
group of people here.
Very conscious of what's
going on in the world.
I think that's my thing
that i would have said well
and i think 73 were 20
years hence. Now. Yeah.
A man comes of age is 21
they say ok and voted 18.
I believe the ukraine movement is getting
of a did just getting towards its
military stage its missionary
stage you probably go out and
and want to change the
world for a little while
and settle down in maybe
10 years time and at
that time it becomes a mature philosophy.
I don't i don't think the i think
philosophy is fact is stretched. From.
Earth's children who go
and sit in the forest
and climb up poles probably to the other
end of the spectrum which was probably be.
In the likes of a few other cities around
but we're not going to you
know if no you know vision.
Well it's going to take
the step on from mars.
I'm hoping it's it's a deed devil lucian
i would i would like to see now is
that we have set this up.
This can be done and we all know
that the next one should be taking a
bunch of young employed people out there
and getting the desert to give fourth
year just to give it a straight
that when you come of age in the
pacific islands. Yeah right.
Of from door here and man
gets presented on marriage
and he selected a partner with
a house and a plot of land.
Yeah that is that is an asset.
He gets we are in society tell people
you've got to turn it off in the beginning.
And that creates poverty. Yeah so.
It is a real good thing to
look at our own processes
and saying what i we really doing
with with our world. Why in fact.
Why is the establishment
in effect trying to.
Well choke the life out of
want to develop a few places
that actually try to do what it's
what we all know ought to be done.
However now we've said a lot of
things about the lismore city council
and i'd like to say one more thing
and this is not by way of apology because
what we've said has been absolutely true.
One individual drove us to
distraction try nancy lee
and emotionally in all sorts of
ways and he was allowed to do
that by many others but the mayor
but three mayors ago we've gone
through about seven mayors.
And five planners and christ knows
how many engineers at all that.
Three mayors ago.
We struck up a report with bob
scullion who was in there that time
and bob put us on the agenda and for
that we're very grateful to him as an
individual since then we've also had a lot of
support from.
The past mayor and the committee and
the represent mayor john crowson
and howard fredericks. So really in fact.
What they did two hours early in the piece
and ripped all our money off
in the end they came good
and i give there's no barrier to
get some more money here in fact.
So the fact that this should be said we
when you reflect on the on the history.
You tend to get stuck and the big learning
experience in the big panes and so on.
It shouldn't be forgotten
that over the last few years we've become
very effective in networking throughout
the various layers of government
and we found very good responsiveness
general boards all the messages about why
we're doing what we're doing. I now
understood by the average average bureaucrat.
And there are some visionaries
within state local
and federal government to
a billy helping us along.
Yet i fear that yeah
that must be said and.
It's about you know any other kind
of stuff you'd like to talk about.
Yeah well. Yeah they are they were they
were all they were all the ones that.
You are sorry i don't say they were the
bunch you could ever repeat our community
pretty aggressive or sorry.
So yeah curry's movement was a bit elitist
because there is such a thing as a
trickle down theory and a lot.
If and you also find
that the ones who had dyno shin the
students did not were not the people who
actually buy a large video. The
tilling of the soil with their hands.
So i think one of the nice things
that has come from a creation
of the real growth things is
that has become a universal movement.
What i want to buy the p.h.
D or what i want to add more
humble occasional qualifications.
Whether you are a great debater of body
you are a silent type what you were a
mechanic or whether you.
You know a nursery man.
It is right throughout
the whole life. Yes.
The thing started with the intellectuals
just like in a hundred sixty eight.
Revolution in paris. Also as a student.
Thing you know that happens with
students but then it comes down.
That's what you pay students for you
know what do you think employers.
I want to doing now as
a 93 already doing now
and i don't do much demonstrating as well.
My daughter to very busy going to work
to support herself so establishing a
successful a actually frightened a lot of.
You.
Well i tell you how we move in here my
daughter was the first kid from here to get
on the school bus and
they used to leave at arc
and seats around
and she had a very hard time for the
first few months into she started like a
little to stick around telling the few
home truth however by the end of her first
year at school she had started
to move into leadership roles
and was being sent away on different
leadership courses at all. News.
She's always been an excellent student
and she's been motivated self-motivated
because the university trip.
She has known since she was 12 that
we couldn't. Afford to support her.
So. In grade 10.
She was the lion's youth of the year
and she did more than any other
there's a big college you know right.
And it's got the choice
of kids from all over.
So there was okay and for the other
kids from this other college
that she went through three of those
she got the one from the state level.
So she did very well that year
and at the end of grady 11.
She won a cow tex award for all
round excellence. Although they did
make a little bit of latitude for her.
They allowed debating to
be reckoned as a sport.
And in her final year she was a student
of the year so she was a particularly
motivated girl. We have
grandchildren growing up here
and now my daughter has
three children at home
and i'm watching my grandchildren
grow up with interests
bringing kids up here. It was hard
to i made a decision to come here.
I suppose and my family
suffered and benefited for
that you know.